haha tu vas l'est pas je ne valide pas
du tout invalide évidemment pas tout
pathé j'aurais il faut pas l'encourager
mon tipi je vais alléger sur manitou
j'ai montré la série à ramzi avant tout
le monde ramzy tout seul chez lui sur
son ordi s'est levé et s'est mis à me
dire tout seul son ordinateur
tellement il faisait prendre à chaque
fois au fond je valide mais là on valide
pas parce qu'on a envie qu'apache il
éclate ou pour la petite histoire ce
bureau qu'il éclate et le vrai bureau
d'olivier nus ce qui est le vrai que dg
d'universal
j'ai veillé tout ce que je valide quand
il accompagné d'une hes je valais pas je
valide pas du tout était méchant et le
mérite des influences pop the fish alors
je sais pas mais ils ont l'air très
content d'aller faire des concerts
c'est pas tes menaces à migros innove
plus tout le laisse à la ramasse au
chalumeau cammas talus ma valise bien
sûr comment
évidemment
[Musique]